private water companies sensible way to
get much-needed investments into
Victorian infrastructure or siphoning
dividends from a public utility were
forced to pay for much of the public now
supports three nationalization a policy
for the first time in decades has a
realistic chance of being enacted the
chief executive of seven Trent is clear
that would take the industry backwards
and threaten services in an exclusive
for this program and her first broadcast
interview i met Liv Garfield far
underground at a sixty million pound
project to create a new sewer system for
Newark so right now we are underneath
one of the main streets of Newark we are
looking at the brand new tunnel boring
machine which is going to create a 60
million pound investment in Newark and
what we're looking at is looking at a
brand new pipe to protect 400 homes from
any sewer flooding going forward so
literally no one has been down here
before this is untouched territory
absolutely untouched territory we're
about 40 14 meters away right from the
very cold front and if we were there we
would literally be able to pour that
tunnel and create to the future and when
did you identify the need to build this
tunnel so about a few years ago we were
looking across the patch and trying to
work out which is the next best place to
spend money on infrastructure in terms
of protecting for the future and we can
see a number of homes in Newark we're
either at risk of flooding or it has
flooding and we took the call that said
actually although it's complicated and
we'll need to build literally 20
different shafts and access points and
four kilometers worth of work across the
bees we knew we could really protect
those homes by spending the money so we
chose Newark and we've worked running
over the people of Newark to be able to
make this a reality but to be clear this
is a cost to the business rather than
anything that's going to benefit you
this is protecting houses from flooding
essentially precisely it's an investment
but I think that's what affected as well
because we spend 150 billion pounds in
the last mr. privatization would you to
spend ten billion pounds over this five
year period and it's an expensive
business's water to invest for the
future but every five years you choose a
few towns and you invest in the
infrastructure and make sure they're
protected for 25 years so what are the
other big projects that you've got on
over this regulatory period so the big
pride and joy right now for seven
friends would be there's a 300 million
pound project where we're protecting the
water in to Birmingham
we've got a beautiful aqueduct which
goes gravity fed 78 kilometers all the
way down from Wales into Burma
and it's been there for a hundred years
we want to be there for the next hundred
years we're currently spending money
investing that of building bypasses
around it creating second access points
to make sure that the use of a product
is still there for the hundred years to
come and one of the big points behind
privatization initially was that the
public sector wouldn't have the money
the resources to invest in upgrading the
infrastructure but I mean this is kind
of a painting the Forth Bridge job isn't
it you've constantly got to be doing
that so you can't go to invest I think
the argument has been proven to be
correct though if you look at pre
privatisation for those 25 years we see
half as much investment over 25 years
post privatisation so private money has
been able to bring it in more funds and
more resources to justify projects like
Newark and that's 60 million pounds 400
homes so to be fair the case would
always be tricky I think private money
has been able to bring that in a lot of
critics will say oh we a spur hang on a
lot of the money's just going straight
out to the shareholders in dividends
yeah but if you look to the facts around
that I'd need to see a hundred and fifty
billion pounds and you'd see a many many
times smaller around that's gonna have
some dividends so I think the fact of
the matter are the sector is an
investment sector one of the things that
you've got to do a surprise he for the
industry is future-proof its population
growth what's that like in seven trends
patch so we actually have a second
highest population growth of anywhere in
the country so 20 percent increase over
the next 20 years so huge influx of
people or growth of population so the
types of things you can imagine we're
doing we're trying to work out where
those people will live we look at the
infrastructure locally we're building
pumping stations were upgrading sewers
but operating water treatment works to
make sure already it's also working with
developers quite early because of course
you can never quite tell what people are
gonna choose to buy homes so working
with them to understand their
intelligence helps us get ready
that's behaviorally how we've behaved
over a long period of time why do you
think it is and that so many people seem
to now support the water companies going
back into public ownership so there's
lots of debate and I don't know whether
we know that that is necessarily case
there's a lot to debate I think when I
look at the facts the facts seem to be
very strong so investment has happened
since privatisation but twice the level
before if you look at the service stats
and I think every single party
politically agrees the service
performance is excellent
sector so you're five times less likely
to turn on your tap and not have water
you're eight times less likely to go
into your lounge and find this water
sewage in it your there's a third lesson
there's a third of the number of leaks
they're ever used to be so I think
everyone agrees on that I think the
debate as I understand it when I see it
players in the press is this is there a
Paik nurse is there lack of transparency
because of the corporate structures it
certainly isn't true for me and seventh
rent we couldn't be more transparent so
I think it's an interesting debate but I
think that the results of the sector
will continue to prove our merit how
worried are you about the possibility of
being green ash analyzed so the things I
worry about I wrote when my customers
turn on this happened they get water I
worry about big infrastructure projects
like this whether we do never been to
time into budget am I not making sure
that my people are safe every single day
and then my customers feel I'm doing the
right thing that's what I'm worried
about and that's what I'll say worried
on